hey everyone this is some footage
comparing marvel spider-man remastered
on the playstation 5
to marvel spider-man 2018 running on a
playstation 4 pro
now on the playstation 5 we ran the game
in fidelity mode meaning the game is
running at 30 frames per
second with lighting enhancements ray
tracing and
additional visual effects on ps4 pro
it's running as
standard because you can't change those
things
footage is just from the first 30
minutes of the game so don't worry about
any spoilers
enjoy fisk
oh
who's ready for their hot fresh cup of
bodily hog
gotta warn you i'm feeling punchy today
let's go
get more backup and lock down the air
space
yuri you okay if you mix it out of that
building we're gonna lose him
i'm gonna go uh
do your thing yes
he's the deck willie
heads up
[Music]
hey where are you going
gotta take those shooters out you're not
bulletproof
come on come on
they shut the elevators down take the
stairs
i prefer a more direct approach
[Music]
spider-man status heading to the upper
floors and hoping nobody turns on the
elevators
our choppers are taking fire looks like
fisk has armed men on every floor
he's desperate and he's hitting us with
everything he's got
i have to find him to end this not yet
we just picked up chatter they're wiping
all their data servers
we need that evidence if we want to put
him away for good okay
server room it is
i heard more people back that way i'll
find them
spiderman we can't move we're pinned
down
i'll lift it when you're free get out
fast if you can walk
healthy and got it
[Music]
[Music]
okay willie coming your way
you guys all right we were just about to
call for backup
i think i'm it lead the way we'll be
right behind you
heads up boss
how is this happening what's wrong willy
you seem angry
i will destroy you
[Music]
get your best shot
that gave me an opening
tiresome annoyance hang in there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so should we kiss now
yeah maybe later
you